now polls have just closed in Italy the
last country to finish voting and one of
the most closely watched
Italy's interior minister Matteo salvini
has been campaigning hard he's hoping
that his right-wing populist League
party becomes the number one party in
Italy and one of Europe's most
influential he is trying to forge an
alliance of European populist centered
around the issue of immigration and
let's go right to Milan DW Thomas Farrow
is standing by for us there he's been
covering the vote in Italy for us hi
Thomas
so polls have closed there do we have
any idea at this point how the results
are looking so me the first numbers have
just been published you can imagine the
reaction here from those first numbers
we can say that the league is said to
have between 27 and 30 percent that is a
bit lower than what they had actually
expected but speaking previously to some
members of the league here they had said
that even if it were below the 30% mark
that they had said themselves then they
would still try and present that in a
way as a victory because it's more than
what they got in any case five years ago
in the European election back then then
for the Democratic Party which actually
won the election five years ago they
obviously have less of a percentage this
time fewer votes but it's still between
twenty one point five and twenty four
point five so relatively good result for
them because according to that they
would finish second even above the five
star movement which is said to have
between twenty and twenty three again
these results have to be taken with a
pinch of salt it's only the first
results that have come out of polls here
and actually have just closed a few
minutes ago so we still have to wait
exactly how these numbers are developed
here in Italy over the night that's
right Thomas but as you're saying you
know this is what Matteo salvini was
aiming for to become the biggest party
in Italy what does this mean for the
other parties are non populist parties
in retreat in Italy well they are
certainly having a difficult time in
particular Democratic Party that's a
center-left
party which has a men
had actually won the election in 2014
they had had around 40% of the votes
back then five years later they have
that so as I say twenty one to twenty
four point five percent so for them that
is certainly a rather bitter result
compared to five years ago and part of
that rule the reason why this happen is
actually because voters have punished
them voters believe that they are no
longer connected to their main interest
connected to what they really want and
many of the voters have actually gone to
other parties like for example a five
star movement that's a clear case here
in Italy so that explains partially why
this has happened we went today here in
the streets in Milan and spoke to some
people about these different issues and
this is what they told us Sakia Shin da
Cunha Kawasaki salvini is doing some
interesting things - Davide majority
deleted Ilan's trying to defend Italy's
rights in Europe okay so to me open for
instance take the battle for the euro
which I think in general has weakened
Italy not Pro salvini
I'm glad that he's involved in the fight
I believe that sometimes a bit of an
iron fist is necessary so our voice is
heard because if we're always too nice
and submissive I think people don't take
us seriously I agree with Savini that we
need to change Europe we would like
another Europe a Europe that cares about
people and less about business so Thomas
interesting to hear from those voices
there are a lot of support for Matteo
salvini
the message that this is our man
standing up for us in Europe on the
other hand we've heard from Matteo
salvini that he wants to reform Europe
from within so what does Matteo salvini
actually want what does you know his
popularity mean for Europe well he
essentially wants to form an alliance
with other part
across the continent that could have
similar views for example when it comes
to immigration that's at least his
stated goal he wanted to become as well
the biggest political group in the
European Parliament the big question to
me is whether he will achieve those
goals given the fact that many of the
parties elsewhere do not share all of
the same views when it comes to Russia
for example when it comes to the economy
different parties describes populist
across the continent have very different
views so what Matteo salvini has said he
wants to do and he will probably do it
as well with this result is to try and
forge alliances with other similar
movements the big question is whether he
will be successful in doing so given
those differences across the continents
thomas's we heard the first results
coming in there it looks like the league
party Matthias Elena's party poised to
be the biggest in Italy our
correspondent Thomas Sparrow in Milan
will talk to you a little bit later